Vince that's insane
we have a new segment here on maa on TNT
tuesdays where we're calling it give
them their roses people that we love
that we want to show love to and we
thought how perfect would it be if Vince
was able to come on as he just retired
we even put this on our NBA the best
reddit stream ever and they're pouring
in if you want to do it on social media
right now just do hashtag Vince Carter
roses and post your favorite clips Vince
we're gonna embarrass you
d-wade your first what is your favorite
Vince Carter story tell it right in
front of them well Adam it's hard to
pick one Vince Carter story but I will
go back to the beginning Vince so 2000
2001 I'm in Marquette University and I'm
I'm red shirting I'm sitting out and my
team went on the road and the Milwaukee
Bucks was playing at Toronto Raptors so
I didn't have a ticket to the game but I
decided to go to the arena and with
hopes that the security who worked our
games because we played at the Brad
listen as well will let me in they did
they let me in and I was sitting up
there with the retired jerseys real high
up but I got there early because Vince
Carter was was famous for his his
pregame workouts right so before the
games started Vince Carter will put on a
dunk show man and like I'm talking about
all the duck contest dunks Vince Carter
will do and one of my favorite things
that you did at the end before the game
started you always grab the net and you
always lift yourself up with their chin
ups on the net and if you know anybody
who know me once I got to the NBA I will
grab the rim before every game and I
would do chin-ups on a rim and it all
started from being that little kid that
young kid that got a chance to get into
the arena to see you want his favorite
players do some amazing amazing things
so thank you for inspiring me Vince
thank you for inspiring a whole
generation of players not only in Canada
but around the world man you are one of
our goats and just thank you thank you
man yeah that's crazy that's crazy it's
awesome hey guess what with the
the funny thing I remember about this is
when we play in the Duncans oh and
that's running down the court together
having a little laugh like what you do
[Music]
me I appreciate you we obviously we've
had some conversation in the past your
favorite Vince Carter story well it's a
two-part story but I'm gonna make a
quick it was three guys that whenever I
played against them I let them do
whatever they want to do Vince
t-mac and white chocolate so dua is
gonna remember this story so we're
playing against the Raptors and I'm you
know telling advance like yo man you got
to do something you got to do something
so this goes baseline against me I got a
flagrant he my man and up and I'm like I
can't have Vince dunk on me
Playgirl I get a file I go to the bench
couple plays later the asian girl has
the ball and tries to steal it from
vince [ __ ] wraps around his back he
comes down the lane and Alonzo Mourning
jumps this edge caught that thing back
and throw her down I'm on the [ __ ] like
this look at that d-wave but he paused
in midair like that was the crazy thing
about the dunk shock is he paused in the
air and led so fall to the ground a damn
booth got a little weak dog calling on
both of us I say he's not gonna let us
do that again he gonna jump out and try
to you know lay us out so when he hit me
but I went higher and it kind of scared
jump I jump harder so while I'm up there
I'm like man don't miss it just dunk it
and that's what I said we're not Dumpty
that's why I was worried about what I
had to be mom well
[Music]
all right let's get to Candace Candace
what is your favorite visitor story they
said personal moments all I have to go
back to is like me turning on highlights
of NBA games where you were playing
against my brother his name is Anthony
Parker in case you forgot and I'm sorry
Anthony I love you but I drove all the
way up to New Jersey to see them Toronto
and the nets in a playoff series and
this is what happened you black my
brother shot off the glass you may
damage it over here you know all that
so at dinners this is you know I got it
I got stories to tell about D way doing
his Pat and spin move Vince doing your
you know inside step ripped through to
the baseline Shaq you know I mean it's
just it's really thank you for making my
Thanksgiving dinners better so thank you
it was one of the top trending stories
on reddit today was our thread of people
sharing their favorite moments of you
Vince a lot of people said the dunk
contest this was won the 2001 series
were you and I ever simmer going 5450
look at this Steve Davidson agree with
everybody the Duncans oh and the
game-winning three against San Antonio
is pretty slept on Vince
I hope you oh and of course Frederick
vice Olympics don't forgot how this is I
mean bring this and put it in your house
enjoy your roses Vince we'll be right
back